Well,
well,
well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
You know what I mean?
Belief floors and then going off fucking morning.
Shit's keep blown.
I don't know how long they need to blow leaves.
I have an idea.
I think they need to do it for about six,
seven hours.
They're leaf blowing duties.
Those are illegals.
Anyways,
so let's shake in
April.
I'm going to have a private and Vegas this week.
Sorry.
Wish I could invite people to it.
And then
April 21 through 23 sperm can Washington at the sperm can comedy club doing
those shows?
That'll be fun.
Um,
May 5th through seventh Jack Shacks,
Jack,
but Jack and shit.
Jacksonville,
Florida,
the comedy zone in Jacksonville,
Florida.
God,
excuse me.
That's the one where they go.
Ready.
Oh my God.
Really Nice to hear.
You know it's your show.
No,
I should've told them not to play that.
May 20th and 21st sperm.
Sperm or sewer,
cute sewer juice,
New York,
the funny bone.
And Syracuse,
New York.
I'm now on sale.
June 9th through 11th.
Irvine,
what do you call her?
Vine.
Sperm vine.
That would be logical.
But we've got sperm kind of
let us know.
Irvine,
uh,
the comedy at the Improv in Irvine,
California.
Uh,
then,
uh,
Jew pork titties.
I'm doing
Caroline's on Broadway.
It's not till September,
but those tickets are already selling.
It's,
that's the city man,
New York.
I'm coming to see you.
And then we're in titties even further down the line,
but also selling,
well the trucker Darrow theater in Philadelphia,
Pennsylvania,
November 19th.
Those are all on sale at Tom Cigarette com slash shows genes.
I thought it was filler up Dell.
Oh yeah,
I skipped it.
Fill her up to Lafayette Yard.
Yeah,
come see me.
April 20th at the Ventura Comedy Club in Ventura,
California.
No name for that.
Well,
Taylor's birthday.
I don't think you need more than that.
Ask for 20 guys.
It's a fun room.
That has been her and I posted it on Linkedin.
I'm invited everybody to be my friend.
Oh wait,
did it super helpful.
And then May 27th of May 28th at the La Jolla comedy star La Jolla.
That's fancy.
San Diego,
La Jolla,
the Jawline,
and then the comedy store like most every week.
Some are on there.
Oh by the time this drops it,
it'll be gone.
Drops dry.
That's what the hip hop or say.
Anybody retweet your show or no,
I'm not going to get into it right now.
Thank you very much.
To Paul who submitted this instrumental beat,
he has sold 45 on soundcloud.
I like it.
I like it til it's very sexual vibes.
Okay,
but be
your ball sack.
Wow.
You rubbed your asshole to this song.
I can see you rubbing your asshole.
That's just reaching back between my legs were around back in the bag.
No,
I would go in between my legs.
Oh,
the song in it.
Cause you were disgusting rubbing your own asshole.
I guess I'll stop rubbing my asshole now.
That's your asshole rubbing music.
Oh Man.
He just rubbed your ass hole before the show and act like you didn't.
I didn't rub it.
I cleaned it in the day.
Walk me through your process.
Can we do the ads first?
And I thought I was just getting into the shower.
So it was getting into people wanted love the pre-talk before their ads.
So
that's what they're paying top dollar for towns,
right?
We had a lot to cover jeans blitz.
What was that command you told me?
Command F for farts.
Come in f four Queens coffee today to see her face.
Is She on here?
Oh No,
it's just a crown.
Nice.
How did you not tell me that though,
man.
What kind of fucking bird are you?
Alright,
are you ready?
Jeans will start to show.
Let's start to show this feature and here's that mom and dad,
the tattoo on the right hand.
See the really big tattoo on the right hand.
Remember that from the white pride worldwide tee shirts.
And then you wait like one more minute into this PBS profile and then we get her
left hand.
And what's her left hand?
Oh,
what's on,
that's the eight eight.
Uh,
hi.
Don't bring in one month into this
role.
Go to your mom's house.
Christina.
Yeah.
Uh,
Hi Hitler.
I love Rachel Maddow.
You love her,
don't you Rachel?
Yeah,
I dunno.
You do.
I thought you really liked Rachel.
Um,
no.
Susie Orman.
You like Suzy?
Oh,
she's your girl.
Yeah,
the finance lady.
Yeah.
I thought you really liked Rachel too,
right?
I mean,
I wouldn't,
I feel weird saying it's not that I dislike her,
I just never considered it.
Like,
Hey,
you know,
I really like,
yeah,
I thought you had a thing.
Oh,
that's Christiana.
I'm,
I'm uh,
yeah,
like Christone one,
four.
Yeah.
She's a journalist though,
or her butthole.
I'd never really thought of Miss Ammann pour that way.
I'm sorry that my wife disrespected you with that question.
Uh,
I consider her a a fine journalist.
Yeah,
she's really good.
Yeah.
Uh,
Rachel's really good at her job,
but she's more like a,
you know,
news sort of evolved or devolved into the business of entertainment and opinion.
Yeah.
So she's really great at what she does,
but she's,
you know,
she's a mouthpiece for the left,
which is fine.
I mean,
I enjoy what she does.
She's,
she's,
no,
it's just what her job is.
You don't have job is that,
and obviously her job is to listen to podcasts.
Well,
clearly she's biting,
you know,
from the show.
Yeah.
She's and I,
and I look in that respect.
I respect that she's doing it.
She's,
well,
she's a Dany Houck first hardcore Dana.
Yeah.
She a duty or your mom's house fan?
I'm not sure.
Oh,
that's interesting.
Yeah,
I mean it could be,
it could be either one.
I guess.
I never really so great that this woman has total white pride.
Coot does Hitler.
Yeah.
Well what state is this and that that's totally acceptable to go to work with?
She's doing and the scope.
What are the age signified,
by the way?
I didn't really know that.
I just know h,
h,
h.
H,
letter H.
Okay.
The eighth letter in the alphabet is h,
is that a,
So Eight,
eight,
eight j you know the thing I don't think she realizes is that he is not going to
respond.
The tattoos,
Hitler's strict watches.
He likes blogs.
You got to record a video and you talked to him that way.
If you do a tattoo or what?
He totally misses.
Well because in Argentina has wifi connection's really,
really good,
but he's still underground so he can only has got funneled through all these
things.
Right.
So if you want to got a busy day,
busy,
just like Winston Churchill,
he lays in bed and he does most of his work from bed.
My Mans got shit to do.
So
he's got a lot of logs,
dancer.
So there's a,
there's a way to get in touch with them.
And right now you're kind of,
you're missing stuff.
I'm a huge Rachel Maddow fan.
Right shot.
I know.
Thank you for noticing.
One of my disciples on the Tom Campaign,
she didn't answer.
Oh.
And I didn't put together this whole time that it is a,
uh,
a Trump thing that we were watching was there.
That's what,
yeah,
she's letting you know what the Trump support team looks like.
Hi.
How are you feeling today?
[inaudible]
wow.
Why does not put up wind in your sail?
Yeah,
I feel pretty good today.
Which,
which Braxton are you feeling?
Paternal.
I feel like miss ie a little bit.
I feel like you know the matriarch of the house right now.
That's what I feel like.
Well that's interesting.
Who Do I feel like I feel like to Wanda?
I normally don't feel it's like Tawanda man,
I'm a no.
I'm feeling a let all like I'm doing my thing.
I'm just kind of feeling her out.
You know,
just got divorced.
I got new heritage.
See anyone knew I'll,
yeah,
I got lots of new prospect.
Oh Great.
That's where I'm fine on linkedin.
My Dad invited us to join linkedin this week.
He did.
He's actually invited us to join linkedin.
So when you know in like the 69 year old set is inviting you to join,
linkedin has jumped the shark completely jumped.
Speak for yourself.
Those of us that are,
that are really in on the inside,
we know that it's,
it's a very,
very relevant like to be a part of Dennis helpful.
Yeah.
It's not a joke.
Play it again.
I love it.
It's a bit that I'm doing.
Linkedin is helpful.
I don't need the help.
Yeah.
I fucking dog assholes.
Linkedin is helpful off.
You know,
Linkedin is helpful.
Yeah,
it is.
I take that challenge.
I wonder is anybody actually using linkedin?
Email us if you've actually found it to be helpful.
Do you think people religion,
can I step in?
Don't do that.
Oh,
okay.
We just don't want to know about your,
like the dead Linkedin is all,
I'm curious,
are you really,
I wonder if anyone really,
apparently people invite you to use it,
but has anybody really using it or not only that,
but is there really a benefit?
That's what I'm saying.
No.
I'm saying like what I'm saying is let's say someone does,
you know what I'm saying?
You know what I'm saying?
And you go,
okay,
then what?
That's what I mean,
what's the utility?
Why not just make it Facebook?
And you know what I'm saying?
It's a smarter right now.
First of all,
we had a lot happened before we started recording today.
Yeah.
You used the name Dennis helpful.
You use the big day.
True.
But you didn't make a brown.
Right?
So what's going on here?
Exactly.
Well,
I mean
I browned earlier and it was fine.
Fine.
Yeah.
And,
um,
and then we just kinda hung out.
I didn't shower before the show,
so I just went in there like a second time for just like a cursory kind of,
make sure you know,
just to feel fresh.
But,
but so you weren't feeling fresh and then you thought,
okay,
little,
you know,
little gaming [inaudible] I just took a little,
French bath.
Yeah.
It's like a horse horseback.
Can I tell you that this bid day?
Yes.
Paid off so much.
It has saved me so many shit to shower trips.
I don't even shed the shower anymore.
Yeah,
it is.
Put a stop to that whole problem.
Yeah,
it's been pretty great.
Right?
Oh my God.
Oh my goodness,
man.
Um,
Ooh.
What was that?
That was,
uh,
my Skype.
I was actually going to tell you that.
Um,
well,
you know,
I um,
I had a bit of an accident this weekend.
I know I didn't want to,
you know,
all right.
At the top of the showtime.
Oh,
you wanted to hold onto all your load already.
Hey,
let's,
let's go over it.
I think it's a pretty noteworthy.
It was,
what was it,
Friday or Saturday?
It all blends together.
It doesn't,
it is all blending Saturday.
It was Saturday.
Yeah.
Saturday
I think
we waited,
we went in the,
and we were having breakfast this morning and I s I started,
I laughed about the fact that I had farted and uh,
I like farting in the bedroom when you're sleeping and when you wake up and
you're upset that you woke up from afar.
It's upsetting to me cause I don't,
that's not the alarm clock of my shoes.
Cause sometimes you'll go like you'll be out and you'll go great.
I was asleep and you know,
I just woke up to your fart and you're like really upset about it.
Yeah.
What woman wants to be awakened by a fart?
Some cool tricks to,
yeah,
there's no checks that like that somewhere down with it.
So I wasn't next to you cause I was in baby Jane's room and I went to go take a
dump in the kitchen and the kitchen bathroom down there.
Right.
And as I'm in there,
I'm just enjoying my time.
I'm thinking I can really relax into this dot because I was watching the baby
once.
I can take a leisurely shit.
Yup.
And Lo and behold,
that gets ruined because what happens is,
as I'm thinking about the fact that I want you to hear a Fart,
if I let it,
I'm not really paying attention.
So when I feel something in the chamber,
I just go aggressive.
And when I push your bottom lamp,
what he did,
I'm sitting on that stool,
there's a bar stool in the kitchen and
I'm sitting there and I go,
oh.
And then I just feel there's no noise.
I just feel water coming in and I go,
I just charted and you go,
no you didn't.
And then I reached down to touch cause I'm like maybe.
Yeah,
yeah.
And it was just all wet,
all wet.
And I go upstairs,
it's just soaked from the sun.
I had to wait,
by the way,
I sat in my,
in my pig stew for awhile because I had to wait for you to come out so the baby
wouldn't be alone.
Yeah.
Cause I was shitty.
I was in the middle of,
I know.
80 years old.
I don't know how to hold in a fart.
I know.
Well,
I didn't start that.
I don't know how to hold in a fart.
I chose to let her rip,
you know,
pushed too hard.
Oh yeah.
Can I tell you what I think your fatal flaw was the wooden stool because that's
a flat surface.
No,
you were sitting on a fatal flaw is that I had,
I didn't have a Fart in the chamber.
I had a dump.
A loose like a six.
A loose meat.
Yeah.
I didn't realize what it was when I sat on that toilet.
It was,
it was bombs away.
It was.
Now let me ask you this.
Let's do an autopsy of your brown shirt.
You didn't feel any indication of a six.
You didn't feel any cramping or diarrhea imminent.
Now,
sometimes I have a real explosive shit to start the day depending on,
depending on the day and what goes in.
And sometimes I don't.
But in this case it was like I woke up,
I had some coffee and then had some,
it was scrambled eggs with veggies,
but that doesn't make
it,
that formula doesn't mean it's definitely going to be loose meat sandwich.
It could be fine.
It's just one of those things where that day it was just horrendous.
No,
and I think it was,
I think it was God punishing you for,
for wanting me to hear your heart.
That's what you told me.
Yeah.
I got it.
Finished.
You.
Hmm?
He's a vengeful God.
Old Testament.
God gets back at you for that kind of stuff.
Let's see if we can get top out it on the phone to discuss this.
I don't know if he'll answer.
I didn't him.
I be calling [inaudible].
Hello?
Hello Buddy.
I invited you to join late.
Hello.
Hi.
Hey Dad.
Hey Buddy.
Hey.
How's it going man?
Good.
Hey.
Um,
so I don't know,
I didn't really get a chance to talk to you,
but Saturday morning I was sitting in our kitchen and we're having a little
breakfast and actually Christina went to use the bathroom and while I was in the
kitchen I went to fart and it was just all water that came out of me.
Oh Shit.
That happened to me.
That nine bed in bed?
Yeah.
Didn't I tell,
you know?
Oh I had a,
I had a squirter in bed and got on the uh,
the bedspread.
Wait and I had to,
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Wait a minute.
Were you in bed,
like going ready to go to sleep?
No,
just laying there watching it in an afternoon TV show.
Cause you know,
what were you wearing?
When I had my boxers when I was kind of a weird position,
so my boxers,
you know,
and we're kind of open.
Okay.
Yeah,
no.
Yeah.
And the kind of like some guy might unaware but some scored it.
Wait,
oh my God,
there's like a,
like a spray
primer stick flats on,
on the bedspread.
So I had to take the best it off,
put it in the Washington.
Wait,
now how she,
how come you didn't think it's just a little bit of shit cause one time you
shortly.
Dot.
Just a miscalculation on my,
no wait,
did you,
so you thought you were farther than you thought it'd just be a fart onsite as
partner for sure.
Did you,
did you push kind of aggressively?
No.
That's what got me,
didn't make this guy to,
you know,
I mean I knew this.
Yeah.
You kind of gave her that little last minute nudge,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
And how,
how much was it?
Cause it sounds like it sounds like a lot.
Well there's a lot more.
I didn't realize it.
That would seem like a little hard at you.
Yeah.
I'm a lot more of their,
you know.
Yeah.
And this body,
you know,
wasn't tons over his body and after they had to change my underwear and change
the whole bed.
Yeah.
So you had to go wash that bedspread,
the whole thing?
Yeah.
Did she did tell Charles?
Did you tell Charl what happened?
I didn't feel it next day.
And then a ship,
mostly her don't,
but the bedspread was doing it in the washing machine.
And I said,
you told her what happened?
She said,
well,
did you clean the spots before you put it in?
Put it in there.
Oh,
it'll get all over everything.
That's what the rinse cycle is.
How did you learn?
How did you tell her what happened?
Like what's the way you tell her that?
Uh,
oh,
by the way,
I had a,
a little bit of a thought.
I was far and it kind of came blast you.
And so I got it on the bed spread and I had to wash the best friend.
What did she think about?
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
she doesn't really like to engage in these kinds of conversations.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean,
didn't you tell me I got that you had one the other day.
You said that like it really curled up into the toilet or something.
Well,
I had,
I had the,
uh,
well look like a snake the other day.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
I mean,
it looked like a rattler with no rattler,
you know?
Yeah.
Just kind of coiled up inside.
They had one of those,
let me say what happened today.
I came back to the office,
had parked under a tree at a fart and then got out of the car,
shut the door.
Andrea was off when I came back.
An hour and a half later,
the smell was still in the car.
I couldn't believe it.
Awesome.
That is really when you think about it,
there's no,
you know,
nothing.
Oh Eric can get in the car.
So he kinda,
he trapped.
Yeah.
It was trips,
you know,
kind of settled in a little bit.
You know,
it's like somebody smokes a cigarette,
the car,
just the door.
You can tell me where smoking.
Okay.
I think you have more intense far,
it's than most people know.
Oh,
I do.
Yeah,
And I've modified my diet lately.
You know,
I've,
I'm on this side eating fish everyday,
can't tramp and orange roughy are trying to lose some weight and so I'm off to
read meek.
Yeah.
And of course that immediately immediately changed the texture.
And,
uh,
and the smell of my four,
everything's changed.
I'm Kinda surprised honestly that you washed the,
she only because you told me real clearly one time that you know when you
started a little bit in your pants,
I said don't you want to put those down?
And you said your quote was it's just a little bit of Shit.
Where are you Margaret has to sleep on the bed.
There wouldn't,
I mean I could if you were alone you wouldn't have watched it.
I had it just sort of folded the bedspread over.
Covered it off
this way nobody could tell.
Yeah.
Cause you have also you have like
the uh,
if you're going to work out,
you have kind of that underwear policy where even if it has a little brown
strict,
you can,
you can put them inside out.
Right?
Yeah.
Well I do that.
Yeah I did.
Yeah.
Sure.
Do you think that's kind of gross?
Well No,
cause I'm an environmentalist.
I'm trying,
you know,
trying to save on water,
cause I saw chocolate stain on one and you just put them inside out.
That's true.
That's drive down to EPSCoR.
Yeah.
But I'm too lazy to just get it started.
You know when you go to the gym is going to get dirty and everything.
So you just go all the way.
Do you know what level of barberry and you are for doing that?
Like that is really,
really horrendous to try.
No,
no discharge.
Do that.
No,
no,
no.
There,
there are certain,
there are certain things,
you know this business where you need to tell your wife,
you know,
we're in alive.
We're going to share everything with each other.
Yeah.
Thanks guys.
Just don't want to share with women.
And it's not about other women when he tell Ya.
Yeah.
I mean,
I gotta say though,
nothing excites me more than the possibility of mom hearing that story.
Just to see her level of discuss would be hilarious.
It would be amazing.
Really amazing.
I'll say Jackie said one time,
I don't know where I met you.
That's hilarious man.
Um,
do you remember your,
uh,
your movie theater Fart?
Yeah.
Oh,
that was one of my proudest moments
was that you think Amit related fart.
You know,
I think it was just eating a lot of stuff.
Probably,
I think it was a holiday fart because Ah,
yeah,
those are real.
A lot of holiday food and in the people or if in the AMC theater people sit
right behind me or let one go.
I mean they picked up and moved five seats over.
Yeah,
no kidding.
I'm not exaggerating.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's a kind of gate kind of gave it that,
you know,
a little notch in my belt.
Luck.
You know what I mean?
Yeah,
yeah.
It was really something we looked at.
Um,
I'll give you a call a little bit later.
Okay.
Okay Buddy.
You take care.
Bye Bye.
Wow.
Wow Dude.
He would have folded over the mattress cover.
Is that what you to do the right thing.
Hey Buddy.
Yeah,
it's top dog.
Hey Buddy.
Stop Dog
Kate Buddy.
Stop Dog.
But do you need to wipe down?
Um,
wait.
So he would have folded over.
So just to be clear,
he shit on the bedspread.
Is that what he shut on?
I think it was a mattress cover the mattress cover
the comfort or maybe you know like that can come for I think something.
It's a comforter he's referring to.
Yeah.
Okay.
So he would have just folded it over.
If you were alone,
you were alone.
Is that most guys though?
Let's be real.
Most guys sympathetically had no,
no,
but it is.
There is a certain type of savage.
I mean military,
just like,
you know,
my dad would just probably eat out of the sink if he were alive,
he'd over it and then just put the food bowl and he's a savage man.
He's a savage.
You money,
doesn't know half of it.
I'm sure she does though.
Yeah.
But I think she voluntarily blocks a lot of things out.
You know,
there's things that like when I'm with them I try to highlight his,
his savagery to see her react.
She knows it's there,
but she avoids it.
So when I keep pointing it out,
look,
look.
She was like,
ah,
no.
So disgusting.
Yeah.
Isn't that interesting that my dad and I it
24 hours apart,
basically.
Very interesting.
And what's really neat too is that sometimes you'll go take a shit and our son
will shit at the same time in his diaper.
I feel like that's the cigarette gene.
It's the circle of Sigora life.
Yup.
Yeah.
That's really neat.
And the earwax thing too,
it's pretty cool.
It's hereditary buddy.
Yeah.
I was pulling earwax out of our son's ear and I was telling you about it.
And then your dad was telling you that it's,
he's told me before on monetary cleaning,
but you're only gonna have like a lot of wax that yes.
Hereditary.
We have that.
I'm like,
fucking great.
What a cool thing to have in the gene pool.
Right.
You know,
treat forearm strength,
earwax pal.
Yeah.
A lot of that.
A lot of waxy years muddy.
And that's really exciting.
Oh my God.
It sounds,
it sounds like he's on track.
Yeah.
Remember that time I saw your dad's balls
yes.
On the cruise.
Yes.
And then he was just like,
Eh,
let's not make a big thing in this.
All right.
She's a grown lady,
like,
are you going to cover up?
Come on said,
come on,
I'm really upset that you wanted to cover at this.
Now your balls to daughter-in-law.
Come on.
So we went out to dinner with your sister Jane,
who's in town and after dinner we were outside all ah,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
Seriously.
And um,
we were out front and I noticed a gaggle of dads.
Uh,
but these dad fashions were a little different.
These guys had the Khakis and then the polo shirt and then they had their
sweaters tied around their necks.
They were doing like the golf course thing,
you know,
like what is that?
That's not really a west coast thing though.
It's like a,
why is this like this?
I didn't touch it really moved.
I didn't touch it.
I swear.
It's a very,
like I,
it feels,
it's,
I think the origins are northeastern preppy.
It's the cat,
the tucked in,
buttoned down or the Polo and then the sweater over the shoulders.
Right.
And kind of either tied or folded.
It's Super Gay.
It's super fucking.
Yeah.
Dude,
that was a lame dad.
Boy City.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It is a little afeminant now for a dad.
Look,
I,
I think so.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
it's just,
it's supposed to be,
I guess it's supposed to be money,
you know,
like I'm a wealthy dad.
Yeah.
I'm a wealthy day and um,
uh,
as president of the,
the dad's society here.
Yeah.
Of Dad fashion fashion week.
Oh,
that would be so fun if we had dad fashion week.
It's then we can take dad's from all the different regions of America and have a
fashion show.
Yeah.
And that'd be neat.
Oh yeah.
I mean it's,
it's definitely,
it's Super Dad.
It's dad.
It's dad to the Max because your dad loves his Khakis.
Like on a Sunday he'll wear his khakis around the house in,
that's his casual Sunday.
It is.
I don't like the sweater folded over with,
oh,
I don't like that.
Look at all like that instead of fag.
You're not saying five boy.
Yeah.
Add,
isolate that.
Thank you.
Yeah.
It's a PC version of faggot.
Okay.
Thank you man.
Thank you.
Plaguing him turning purple.
And he said it was my request.
Fucking trader blue.
Then a sham.
You bird.
I look at a gee,
gee,
why don't you tell him what happened?
I know I broke him today.
I broke him today.
I,
I knocked this over,
but look,
here's the good news there.
Is that GG,
hold on
and then there's many GG.
All right.
Back in business,
if you don't have a backup GGL and bobble head,
you better get your life.
If you're a real fan,
you have your primary and then your backup camera.
You fucking did that.
You know what?
I can't say faggot.
I'm going to say fuck boy.
Okay.
Yeah.
How do you isolate it?
Huh?
Three times you had to do it.
Had to catch me on that.
That's my favorite one.
Yeah.
Thanks.
If I can say Faggot,
I got it.
Fuck boy.
Okay
guys,
my documentaries coming out.
Can we take a joke?
Lemonade release this summer,
Samuel Golden Mayer picked it up.
I saw actually a lot of people talking about it online.
Supposed to be really great.
I narrated it.
It's not my documentary.
[inaudible]
upon a story being,
if you're offended by that,
what you just heard me say about fuck boys,
don't go see that document.
Fuckboy responses this week too.
Is that right?
Oh,
they were like,
that's not a replacement
for what Tom?
Uh,
a replacement.
And if I can't say Faggot,
I'm going to say,
fuck boy.
Okay.
For what time?
I go like,
no,
it's not.
It's fucking stupid.
And of course it is.
You guys are fucking fuck boys for saying that.
It's 100% a plus.
What it sounds like it is,
I mean,
the origin of Fuckboy is prison.
Okay.
Oh right.
Yeah.
And it's somebody who people would fuck there.
Hence it's a replacement.
Yeah.
It's a buff guy.
You fuck,
it's not,
it's not necessarily a replacement for the,
the literal pejorative homosexual slang.
What I'm saying is that it's replacing in the lexicon something that people want
to angrily shout.
Right.
With the intention being to take someone down,
accused them of being lesser than whether that be a feminist or just a bitch.
Right.
It's,
it's a,
it's a heightened version of bitch,
but it's also something that you can yell freely basically.
Yeah.
It's an acceptable form.
It totally is.
And it will become politically incorrect and all you fuck boys the disagree or
fuck boy.
Now what I did hear one of those dads doing in front of the restaurant.
Yeah.
As the dad throat clearing.
Uh,
yeah.
And I had a Stepdad that did that for a years.
I think a big fat Indian guy was pissed that dad and he would always do that
after restaurants after meeting with your mom.
My mother hated it cause he's in the morning too is like,
it's so disgusting.
You hate and clearing cause I do it.
Um,
I know that growing up my mom hates when I clear my yes.
What does that,
I don't know.
Oh I think it's the phone being too close to the thing.
All right.
Yeah,
that sound is repulsive to me that I want to vomit when I hear that.
I see.
To me,
I guess I understand it,
but you know,
I,
one time I left a lunch meeting where the guy producer,
we left the restaurant and on the sidewalk he went,
ha,
any spit and a guy walking down the street when really I agree.
He was like,
well no.
And I actually was,
you know,
it's one of those things,
you leave a meeting like that with people.
You have to go like,
what's that guy's problem?
But I should have been like,
what is your problem?
Because gnarly,
gnarly.
It wasn't so neuro that he and I put it on the cement.
Like that's crazy.
That's fucked up,
dude.
He Chinese.
That's true.
I'm my Chinese ex boyfriend use talk about that all the time.
How Chinese people do that.
Yeah.
He's like,
oh,
the Chinese are the worst.
They just horrible.
Loogies everywhere.
And in places like Singapore,
you're definitely not allowed to do that.
Yeah.
Um,
wait,
why is that not isolated?
Like Tom Pushes the just,
I didn't do that.
That's not,
that's you pushing the change on button.
Do anything.
I didn't do anything.
Hey,
want to fuck with my mind,
so,
okay,
well,
Singapore just has laws,
period.
You don't fuck with anything.
It's spit chewing gum on the ground.
No,
no,
no.
It's,
it's,
that's that,
that place doesn't fuck around.
And they have,
um,
signs when you walk through,
when you're waiting in line immigration,
you've been there signs that say,
you know,
this,
this and that are punishable by death.
And then on the slip,
the little immigration slip,
it says drug trafficking punishable by right
death.
Hell yeah.
Big Red Letters.
Yeah,
dude,
don't as the Singapore.
And the crazy thing is,
people know that and they still will take that risk.
And I know is I ran into
people,
I talk to me,
we'll actually listen to this show there that was,
you know,
bringing up the rules.
And they were like,
yeah.
You know,
some guy,
they got a guy recently,
he was in the news that in the bottom of a laptop he had packages of the week
and then they executed him.
Damn did.
And they can't help you if you're American.
Right.
And you fuck up like that.
If it's drugs,
you're done,
you're done.
You know they got that,
that kid for a vandalism.
That's right.
And they came in him and they negotiated less,
you know,
less white paintings.
Yeah.
And that kid did graffiti,
right?
Yeah.
Stupido tagged up some cars and stuff,
but oh my God.
The,
the truth is,
you know,
if you go,
if you
bring drugs there,
you're just yes.
So dumps done just on,
don't travel abroad with drugs.
Don't even fuck with drones.
Oh Man.
God traveling with him is really crazy.
Yikes.
Yeah.
Crazy.
That's how you,
this,
I knew this girl that used to travel with drug.
She put them in her panties in the,
you know,
girls' panties.
There's a thought or your COO dress.
Yeah.
There's like a double layer of fabric and she'd put her drugs and that little
pouch.
It's a good spot for it.
Uh,
uh,
Supreme Lee.
Good spot for it.
Yeah.
No,
we're really not going to check your coach.
You know,
I know a guy that told me he used to travel with it under his nuts.
That's sub what's sub?
Apparently the crotch is the best area.
Yeah.
But under your nuts.
You gotta make sure you've got big nuts that don't,
you don't ever shrivel on you.
Right.
It's very important.
Yeah.
Big Old goat nuts.
Make your dad's got big nuts.
Big
Balls.
I know that a lot of you wanted to know about if there was,
um,
an update on the ass eating girl.
Um,
oh yeah.
I was really thinking about her all week.
We played her last week and she gave her,
um,
review of ass eating and in the end you could say that she said not that bad.
That's the best way to summarize it.
And she was sent to us so many times.
Your mom's house listeners really wanted us to see that shortly after we played
her though her video went private.
Really?
I think she was getting bombarded.
The mommy's attacked.
I think just,
you know,
I think that that video might have just caught fire.
So then she posted this about,
I guess the re this is her posting since the gas heating video.
Okay.
So recently I was featured on Youtube,
snapchat,
youtube snapshots,
Facebook page.
Not Shots.
MMM.
Seeing video pretty okay.
Pretty Mad.
Why?
Um,
because now that in famous,
I'm not getting the respect I deserve.
Um,
and we need everybody to start
treating me as you would treat.
MMM.
A famous person because I'm famous now.
And
is she a great actress or is this real?
Because I was actually watching.
I was like,
this is actually really good acting right.
Selling that or it's genuine.
Let's continue.
I'm not sure.
Separate argument here when I say that because now that I'm saying this and then
if you are allowed to be mean to me and also in thickness now because I was on
youtube,
snapchat,
snapshots and [inaudible].
Hmm.
I spoke to Macaulay Culkin this morning through prayer and he wants me to tell
you to
hurry to him more often.
It looks like she drank some other Dany Erica late.
Uh,
someone's off their meds
to Colleen,
my colleague.
He's still alive.
He's dead.
Finally.
He's not dead.
You should be paid.
Why?
He does bad drugs.
He's on heroin.
Come on.
I love Rachel Maddow.
Sub chipper
this check,
because if you don't already
is her fucking deal brown.
You who are inside of a colleague Caulkin when you know that he's actually,
he's a fan of me because I'm famous now.
Like I'm more famous than him and that's definitely not true as know that I'm
offended by everything you do because you don't just cause I'm,
what would it look like?
Sound pepper.
Holy Shit.
What do you think?
What's the verdict?
Well Macola Caulkins definitely more famous than ass eating girl on Youtube.
Yeah.
Even if she was on youtube,
snap,
snap shots,
five shots,
pop tarts,
stop jobs.
You know what?
We should do a show this to our son when he's of the age of making videos,
right?
Yeah.
This is why you don't do,
you don't do this because stupid.
We're going to humiliate you on this.
[inaudible] sure.
Yeah.
Still Book Kid.
What do you think?
So I definitely think there's some danger,
Yak.
There's some,
Danny had qualities to her.
That room,
I dunno.
I don't think she's acting actually.
I think Senator [inaudible].
Yeah.
It's a lot.
And that's a lot to handle.
Well,
she's famous now.
I think it's funny that that is actually the thing that
people in the general public are always not prepared for.
Um,
when something gets attention like a video,
right?
Cause like if you do,
if you do comedy over time,
as your profile grows,
you build up a little bit and then it grows up a tolerance to people
disrespecting you and treating you like shit.
Right.
Online.
Yeah.
So after it happens a bunch,
you're like the Harris.
Yeah.
But if you're just like a regular person and you post videos,
you don't,
you don't normally get hate and then you have something that explodes,
like the aspect of it,
then you're like,
why are people
validity?
It's gotta be the most shocking to them,
you know?
Yeah.
Cause what did you think was going to happen?
That people are like cool ass eating video.
We really like what you're doing.
Yeah.
I got to ask.
You can eat.
Yeah,
it's good.
It's all,
it's all Puerto Rican guys.
Yeah.
You got to eat this and because he's my ass.
He my ass know,
you know,
that's all she's getting right now.
Right.
I gotta ask you [inaudible] Commercial Maya ass.
Muncha Muncha Muncha Muncha yeah,
of course.
Then she's a horrible,
poor.
All demanding respect.
It's hilarious.
Okay.
Uh,
no,
I just love it.
The pimp squad.
You miss her.
Some people are gay.
My
uh,
yeah,
it just makes it wasn't good and she's great man.
There's another a man,
this is
so demeaning and so funny.
I was watching underworld inc on um,
on Netflix and they have,
you know,
a different underworld.
Documentary episodes basically.
Yeah.
Guns,
drugs,
sex
trafficking.
Like we pitched this show,
I pitched a show in the 90s.
Yeah,
I know.
So it's like a spice,
right?
Yeah.
Cover all the cool stuff in life.
They have this dude,
um,
on the show.
Let's see.
I want to make sure I,
I,
I certainly wouldn't want to disrespect this pimp.
His name is big town and uh,
he's riding around Oakland shouting out to his girls.
Well,
he,
uh,
I'll just,
I can't do him justice,
so just watch him do his thing.
Oakland,
California International Boulevard is a well known track.
Were prostitutes.
Ply their trade.
You're about to getting your waves.
Bitch.
Former drug dealer.
Big Town works.
The shops in town,
big town offers a warped idea of providing protection to him.
Women aren't people,
their assets,
he controls.
He has a management style man.
You guys stay positive.
Big
Girls Give me 100 motherfucking percent of every dollar that their pussy for
deuces.
That's what I'm talking about.
A deck.
That is my fucking man right there was the town.
Big Town.
Yeah.
Can we see his face?
They don't show his face.
No,
they don't show his face because he's the pamp.
Yeah,
of course.
He um,
stays pamper.
What'd he say about wings?
He said something about where to get Joe wags.
Prostitutes ply their trade.
You're about to gain your waves bitch
to fly away.
I Dunno.
Take the wings.
I was thinking about eating them,
but yeah,
me too big at Joe Wang.
Bitch.
Ooh God.
Let's see what else he's got.
Good one.
These hoes
big town is a Predator always on the hunt for new merchandise to add to his
stock.
Do you are a right triangle?
Dwell track.
That's how he gets a home.
Can I get a hell?
Yeah.
You on raw ride train with the wrong track.
Yeah,
baby.
And then some girls like,
oh yeah.
Can I give you 100% of like a guy could work for?
Yeah,
prostitution is 100% more profitable drugs.
Oh yeah.
That's for sure.
You could stay at $1,000 dress and these holes once you get fist one whole clear
what you put out their first night as you're doing this real.
So I then did a day prostitution is 100% profit here.
That ain't gonna work.
Bitch.
Get off that phone.
This asshole.
By the way,
he's so fucking fat and lazy that he just drives around and yells insults.
He doesn't even walk up to them and solve them.
Well,
you can also hear his mouth.
You're good.
He's got the biggie smalls.
Yeah.
Well it's also a terrible part about Oakland.
California is also blessed with what Nigga selling pussy.
They got so much good apply to deal with,
man.
They don't have the manpower.
Donate to the prostitution.
Oakland coincides with pimping man.
Niggas calling mag him a plan.
Do check and money up out a bitch.
That's what you doing,
man.
Yes.
Some hold on.
I like that.
Hodo equals money from probably no,
we put that to that birds.
Thank you very much.
Yeah.
Damn.
This guy's already legendary,
man.
That's for real.
I'm a loving.
There are severe consequences if his asset doesn't hand over all the dough.
A check.
What's the rest of the house?
Getting the rest of the house?
Getting 800 you keep bringing me so 50 or 500 I might go for that first night.
You do that again the second night.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm gonna check on the rest of the house for my money that you can hide.
If I find it,
I'm gonna beat the fuck up out.
You
do stone to the grail from the rest of the house.
You know,
so we get a demonstration.
Y'All get a good idea of what's going on,
but see,
that's just no,
no.
Gorilla pimp and get that clear.
Um,
he's a real piece of shit.
Just a different management style.
Yeah.
It ain't that a bitch got a black guy,
but I am fucking would hose.
So I do got straighten number hose.
Every man did
this guy already wait a minute.
No,
he's not.
Well,
look at his arm.
It's a little pinkish.
Well,
I'm s he's anything,
he's like,
I'm Mr. White folks.
No,
no,
no.
This guy is,
he's,
he's black man.
He's Mr. White Folk.
Sounds black.
He's super black.
Okay.
But preventing women from going independent is the key to his business.
The thoroughbred.
When a guy made a whole day.
So they call it renegades again.
We've heard this term right?
And the other documentary.
Yeah.
These are homes that want to do it on their own.
Right.
Renegades.
Yeah.
I love that.
She's as,
as opposed to entrepreneurs,
entrepreneur,
what is what they is
tear it off a door and the garbage can put that on the 10 o'clock news.
That's where I think about a real,
when a gay man that's terrible looking at home,
he stabs targeting.
What'd you looking at?
How crazy person talk shit dragging his business.
And then he's like
to looking at home
Jassal what a piece of shit this guy is talking about beating the out of girls
and then he only pauses to yell at them from the car.
That lazy piece of Shit won't even get out of his car to yell at them.
Yeah.
Unbelievable.
A lot of good guy.
But now it's all,
but I really wish we could just legalize this so that these girls don't get
their ass kicked by this dumb fucking hate.
If that happened.
Hey Man,
can we,
do you mind playing be weesies new jam.
Oh,
it's so good to me.
We got to promote the,
should we play the first one that we originally debuted on the show?
Sure,
sure,
sure.
The party line.
Well,
it's kind of long,
right?
Oh,
you're right.
Okay.
Well
you guys know,
um,
Brown wine box.
He's actually,
he's been on the show before.
Um,
he,
he made gangster party line two years ago.
We played it on the show and we are this one word.
I definitely responsible for this going viral.
This went viral because it is fucking hilarious.
Tastic um,
Brown Leinbach that's his name.
Look him up.
His standup is hilarious.
Just like a little bit of a,
it has 4 million views now.
Oh Shit.
This is at your party line
Nigga.
You want to talk some shit?
Start some shit bitch.
You gotta Talk Shit about me Homie from Hudson.
Niggas is waiting for your motherfucking call and they all talking shit about
you right now.
That shit.
These motherfuckers say asap.
Yeah.
Assessed some shit.
Fuck you on your boss purse.
The hardest Niggas is standing by ready to pick up that phone.
So okay.
Dork niggers,
Asian niggers,
White Niggas suck my Dick Bitch.
Fuck you.
One,
two,
one,
three,
seven,
four,
two,
five,
three just down Nigga.
Fuck you up.
Deaf Niggas.
Classic Niggas,
racists Niggas,
mystery Niggas.
Psycho Niggas.
Y'All niggas Jewish niggas.
He got some mother fucking nerves calling me.
I'll should but also little bullshit ass Nigga calm that shit down and come
right here.
Show me some fucking respect.
He phoned me and my Jewish Nigga come up here and beat your ass Nigga off top
niggas talking shit,
call now foreign 99 per minute.
One of the great thing about me,
there's a lot of great things that um,
as he did,
but do you know that um,
that number is live.
It's a real phone number you can call and uh,
God brand,
one of the great things is that
um,
he'll,
he will answer that,
that phone sometimes I'll,
I'll still answer it.
They play voicemails from it sometimes cause people,
he has the option to put it to voicemail but sometimes he'll just answer and
talk shit to you.
So it's pretty amazing box of shit.
I want to talk some shit money anyways,
fair sketches.
Brent has made a number of really good youtube videos like that on his latest
one is here.
It's man.
So fucking watch this a few times this weekend.
Yeah,
really funny.
I'll just play it.
This one's not that long so we'll play it for you here.
Yeah,
it's a,
here we go.
All right guys,
guys,
check it out.
When I'm about to do was apply mind manipulation.
What's your name?
I'm Nathan.
I want you to relax.
Stare into my eyes.
Think about what I'm thinking about
for people listening.
This is like a David Blaine [inaudible] street magician.
Jack.
Yeah.
Share my thoughts to the mines.
Equally.
One fiery mind.
Focus.
Nathan,
look down.
you're just busting a nut.
Oh Nathan,
look again.
Hello.
How are you doing
Nigga got or something.
It's amazing.
So good.
Cause it'll street magicians.
It's so corny to me.
Yeah,
it's pretty cool.
But it's corny.
Unbelievable.
Same time.
What happened to my,
Oh,
here we go.
Nice for myself down too low.
He's so funny.
Dude.
Fucking bullying.
Bully boy.
Oh boy.
That's a slim Jesus.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah,
he did it.
And then if I can't say Faggot,
I'm going to say fuck boy.
And then you said,
I'm just waiting for a new song.
You're the worst.
You know that.
You know Tom,
I trust you.
I do this show with you and then you,
you know,
you manipulate.
Know why that would not matter.
Savages,
you are fun.
Bullying,
you can't hang.
I like that song.
You liked the song?
Yeah.
Who is this slim Jesus did Jesus,
a white kid that works at Walgreens that say you shouldn't be pulled up?
Okay.
Yeah,
he's pretty good.
Um,
okay.
Wow.
Yeah,
it's pretty great.
Anyway,
that was pretty funny.
It'd be ways is good.
BBZ is good.
You know what's really in our cool is that I had a jacket that I had tailored,
uh,
cause I was super fat when I deliver.
After I delivered the kid and I got this nice jacket and I had a tailored so
that I could look normal on stage.
And then I came home from the comedy store the other night and I was so happy to
wear it and I like debuted it.
And that happened.
You said,
oh you look like an art teacher.
Can we post a picture of you in it?
It's on my Instagram.
It is me at the comedy store.
I'm on stage wearing it.
It's a black and white,
I guess.
Kind of like a hounds tooth.
Can you pull it up?
Yeah,
I like guys are like fucking bro kill.
You know what I'm saying?
You don't always look really cute.
And then you told me I looked like a fucking high school art teacher can use her
shit.
That's right here.
This is it.
It's black and white,
but it's a black and white coat.
So it doesn't need to be shouting,
shouting you.
Can you look,
I mean blue man,
is that really,
that is it really that bad?
Okay.
I was feeling pretty good about myself too.
I came,
I was feeling myself.
I was feeling like Tamar,
I came back on auto focus
on top.
There's an auto focus button.
I came back from the store and I felt as good as tamer
is auto.
It's on manual.
Oh,
that's why.
Yeah.
Okay.
Uh,
what's not.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So what do you think of the photo though?
Uh,
our teacher.
No,
no,
no.
Thank you.
Blue Man.
You can't really tell on this picture though.
To be fair.
We should take another picture.
Fine.
We'll take another photograph of my code that I had tailored to fit my fat
postpartum body to make me feel better about myself.
Say That and then,
you know,
oh,
look at you.
You're an art teacher.
Thanks Tom.
What,
what are you doing?
Where are you going through?
My is just too much going on over here.
Why are you going through my Instagram account right now?
Why can't I go through it?
Because it's my phone.
Gimme My,
my phone.
Let me see what else you got.
You don't let me go through your shit.
Give it to me.
How come you know the codes to all my shit?
I don't know any of the cozy or shit.
She going through my shit just now.
Just to see what's going on.
Yeah.
You don't need to see what's going on.
Why not?
You're a fucking look at the CC this thing.
This cat burka.
Yeah.
We got this for our dog.
Busy.
You should show this to any of it.
Yeah.
This is,
uh,
the dog.
The solution to the bitsy problem.
We can't stop her from eating everything.
Giving herself diarrhea.
So I bought her a burka.
Yeah,
put her on her face and her covers her mouth so she can't eat stuff and it's
been working so far.
She hasn't had diarrhea and like a week and a half.
I like to have your password to your phone to cause you the passcode is all my
shit and I don't have any two years.
What do you really annoying.
I just want to look through your stuff too.
Like oh look at my stuff,
Ya know,
I know I'll be fucking on the couch and you'll just be like,
dude,
did you?
I'm like,
where's my phone?
You're like,
oh,
I'm on it right now.
Blah Blah Blah Blah.
Ordering food,
doing things,
ordering Amazon.
By the way,
if you have an a already bookmark your mom's house bike has dotcom com.
Use the portal on our home.
Paige to shop on Amazon.
I don't go through your phone.
You totally do.
I seem to never go to your phone and use all my apps.
You're ordering door dashawn here we instacart.
Okay.
Sense that we use the APP on one person's phone for things coming to the house.
All right,
so when we owed or groceries or dinner or something,
we do it on that end,
but you hand me the phone,
you go here.
I mean,
you act like I'm taking it,
but then before,
but I'll be doing something else and you'll be on my phone looking at my
picture.
No,
I don't.
Why was this picture?
No,
I don't.
I do not.
I'm not interested in going through your phone.
We had killer Thai massages on Friday.
You want him,
ma?
Not Tom hates couples massages.
Have we talked about this on the show?
I don't think we've had it up.
Oh,
where the,
the lady one time goes one,
two couples massage.
Tell him what God,
no,
God,
it sounds fucking terrible.
I was like,
relax.
And so you made a big thing of it.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah,
it's a little embarrassingly here.
My husband,
we're supposed to do stuff together.
We did do stuff together so they didn't want to put us together because then you
go,
oh,
is she going to be able to walk on my back?
Yeah.
And they're like,
oh no.
90% the same womb.
So then they had to give a separate rooms where they say,
I don't remember.
You just said it though.
I remember,
but you just said it.
No,
no,
no.
Cause I said I hadn't slept a lot.
You're going to walk on my back and you go and they said no,
not at,
not in the same room sir.
That's it.
Then they put you in another room and did she walk on your back?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's good.
My lady weighed about
two 50 she listens to the show,
maybe she courses to the show.
There's no way she listens to the show and she jumped up on my bag and I had
that moment of like,
oh fuck,
she's two 50 at least I thought she was going to break me for sure.
So I had to be like,
oh I just had a baby three months ago.
Take it easy on me instead of you're too fat to be just sitting on top of me.
Cause what do you do?
What?
She's a big then she,
oh I'm
so sorry.
And she backed up,
you know.
But what do you do if she's a big old bitch?
You do the heavier,
the better actually.
Seriously.
Really?
Yeah.
Cause you feel the,
but you said she was too hard on you this time and she was not big.
That's the,
I could not believe it.
She was tiny and I was like,
oh,
like my eyes were watering.
I was like,
Jesus.
But she also was doing things that didn't really like,
there's certain parts of like,
you know your Shin or your,
your outer like the quad,
I forgot the name there where it's sensitive almost I think on everyone.
And she was going full pressure off.
I'll go,
ha ha,
like that.
And she goes,
ah.
And they always laugh when you ever,
I was like,
wow.
She's like,
I only think it would take it easy there.
Oh,
okay.
My favorite,
they stretch you and it's always too much.
It's always too much of a stretch.
Yeah.
My inner thigh mean Israel delicate and she was mad.
I was like,
dude,
sometimes the stretches are too aggressive that he did a,
I was facedown,
takes my leg up,
like bend at the knee and then immediately push it to my,
I was like maybe ease into that.
You know,
why don't we do it?
And kind of steps.
I don't like when they crack anything on me too.
I'm interacting.
I like,
I like crack but I don't trust the neck a crack.
Oh are we used to live on the east side and we used to go to the same place like
every time there was a girl who would go like take your time to go.
She just snap your neck.
Well cause these motherfuckers are not chiropractic.
No qualified.
And they would just like whisk her off to another,
a massage place.
They'd be like uh,
Kathy killed somebody.
Make her go to Kathy.
That's always there.
Dan.
Cathy,
why did he kill someone?
Sent her over to sunrise massage because she can't work here no more.
But this place was nice cause you noted that it didn't smell like they're stinky
food sometimes with with ty.
It'll just be like a restaurant because they're all bring in.
Yeah.
And it stinks like a fucking restaurant.
It's always real spicy to tally.
Well that's going to give you a ring stand.
Sometimes I smell their breath when they put your face up and then I closed
garlic breath.
One thing I don't like to hear is when it,
um,
when the massage takes too much out of the person,
you hear them breathe and their like
and I'm like,
dude,
I'm not going to relax with you hyperventilating or wait here.
Yeah,
that's true.
But the time is,
I just always a great cause it's dirt cheap.
It's so cheap.
That's the whole thing you can do.
You feel you can do it all the time.
It's so cheap.
One time I went to a resort,
it was,
my dad had a business trip and I went there and I had like,
it was like a five star resort,
had a spa and I go,
I'm gonna go get a massage.
I call it him to think to specify things that gave me an old man.
Yes.
And during the massage he was like,
like every pressure thing.
I,
it sounded like it was his last breath every single time.
It's just
all I listened to the whole time was this guy breathing.
I hope you enjoy yourself.
This is my last massage and it was,
it was rough,
man.
I used to go to this guy.
This one guy in silver lake.
Oh yeah,
we heard a lot about him.
Yeah,
he's great.
Apparently though he was touching the tits cause I sent him,
I said other girls to him and he was touching their tits.
Nice.
Well I'm saying you shouldn't do that,
but nice.
He never touched my tits.
Sure.
Suburbs.
This conclude the tape.
Why could you flip over?
Give you a tip.
Massage.
Now
what if that is the reason it's going in?
Of course that's terrible.
It could be that,
but apparently he was feeling up all the other people.
He never phoned me up.
Maybe you wanted a little bit.
Two of my friends,
they said that he felt
so.
Did you um,
they said that they felt him up that day.
When you,
when you go on your bag that he was giving them tiddy massage.
I don't think so.
This guy was a little,
a feminine.
He wasn't,
you know,
he never did it to you?
Not once.
Why you think he did not?
Because I've got huge sloppers.
Why would he not want to feel those?
He didn't know where they began and where they ended or something.
I don't know.
Okay.
No,
because I don't,
I don't know.
I don't know why.
Maybe he saw you come in with me a few times and he knew like this bitch has a
bear.
Got a big bear with you.
Um Hm.
Yeah.
Do you miss him?
I do,
yeah.
I was kind of contemplating driving to go see him again.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
Good guy.
He was really good.
I don't to be still there.
That's really love,
man.
I know and I'm so bummed because I are a few people that we left behind at her
old place.
Really good.
Once you,
that's hard to find.
Once you find that special person,
their price is right.
They do the shit.
You didn't want to leave him,
you know?
Nope.
My life is hard.
Life is hard.
We kind of makes you want to listen to this.
That like for me,
even if who knows what happens with the film,
but like that work so shocking and crazy that I was like,
Whoa,
I can't believe I did that.
But it feels really good too.
It gets things out of you.
I don't know.
That's acting for me is when I feel like something from my life like really
was undone and released.
That's a Kirsten Dunst and that's curious and dance.
Oh Wow.
She did a little vocal fry.
They're kind of up there with the,
uh,
the Lord of all Improv.
His birthday.
It was birthday was a just yet yesterday I believe.
A smurf day.
Steven Sea Gal,
Gal turned 64 years old.
Uh,
we should point out that he has a couple films that just hit Netflix.
No,
uh,
I think a good man and absolution or now,
now on Netflix.
We should watch those.
Um,
we should check those out.
I would love,
so we should.
Um,
but can we sit through the whole film?
That's the problem.
That is the,
the real challenge.
Here's the,
do you think we can sit through the whole film?
Okay.
Yeah.
Gosh,
it's really,
at first I thought it was a start.
Uh,
uh,
it's really something,
right?
She may listen to actor.
Right.
And here's a seek out.
Uh,
yeah,
she's a good actress.
She's,
and she was great in the Fargo.
Fucking amazing.
Yeah.
She's really talented.
I like her a lot.
Fargo Fargo.
Sorry.
Uh,
by the way,
we have finally we caught up on better call Saul and how sofar it's,
we're finally getting into it.
Caught up now,
but we're starting to finally,
yeah.
I'm not really fucking,
I dunno man.
It's making me very,
very unhappy.
Why are you so upset,
Tom?
I like when Francis and Clare,
but sniffing Underwood.
Yeah,
I liked it.
They were psychos and I liked that they were,
you know,
just winning at all costs.
Savages.
But I like when they're together.
Yeah.
When they are team Jean's team genes.
When they put one leg in each panel and they pulled him up.
But now this new season,
I don't want to give anything away,
but they're very against each other if it's jeans against jeans.
Yeah.
And I agree.
I'm not interested in,
yeah.
Yeah.
I know.
I like to see them as a team.
Cosby team trials.
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
I know.
But,
uh,
you know,
Claire's,
but it looks like it smells fresher than ever.
She's really,
really spice you on that stuff.
Straightened that ass.
Stretton that
she um,
yeah,
she's flexing it man.
She's really like,
we'll see what happens so far.
It's very interesting.
Yeah.
I'm on board by the way.
I was watching a little bit with my sister was here with her,
uh,
fiance and um,
we started to watch peewees
big holiday.
Right,
right.
That's a new movie.
You know what would amaze me?
Um,
they go,
how old is peewee?
And I said,
uh,
he's gotta be late forties.
I was assuming,
you know,
and anyways,
I looked it up.
Do you know how old he is?
Fifties 63.
Peewee Herman.
63,
63 years old.
Wow.
Credible.
It makes sense because what it does when you really think about it,
yeah,
but it's still,
wow.
He looks great,
dude.
Pee Wee Herman is special effects really to make him look younger.
Blue man says,
oh,
in that film
thing,
I read an article on it like yesterday.
Oh,
so he read an article the man says,
and they made him look younger.
I guess he's a character has to be that young.
The whole thing is that the character is,
yeah.
Think Eternal Youth,
but yeah,
but we're talking about a guy who's not far from 70.
Right.
Still looks great even being,
you know,
that whole thing.
It was so sad that he lost his career over Jerkin it in a porno theater who
hasn't done that.
Right.
I mean,
if I had half his career,
I'd be fucking in the dumps.
Right.
Many times over.
I've jerked off and fucking phone booth hospitals,
right?
Yeah,
right.
Funerals.
Absolutely.
My Dad's funeral.
Your Dad's feet.
But see,
I mean,
look of all places to jerk off in public.
That's kind of where you're supposed to Jack.
It is at the movie theater,
the plays dirty movies.
And he got really reigned for that.
I read a little recap about it.
Um,
it,
you know,
just because I had just read about him and apparently,
there was like a sting operation going on there and they had arrested some
people in the theater and he was actually walking out and someone spotted him
and it's almost like they were like,
oh,
that's,
and he goes,
I'm peewee Burmis and then get him.
And then he offered the police department to do a show for free for like kids in
the area to make the story to go away.
Yeah.
And then his lawyers also approached the da with that with like,
can he do it?
They were like,
no,
of course not.
That's terrible.
Oh God.
Well,
when you think about the transgressions of other famous people like George
Michael,
wasn't he jerking it in a bathroom stall?
No blow jobs,
no job and didn't ruin his career.
Yeah.
Well that sucks.
The thing that Sucks for a pee wee is that he was a chill guy.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
can we teach our kids about masturbating?
Is that not part of the curriculum anymore?
I mean,
your dad probably showed you how to masturbate very early.
That's one thing that he was not,
those two didn't talk about that.
Huh?
Not even a tiny,
tiny bit.
And that's,
yeah,
no,
I don't think my parents told me,
I can remember a couple of masturbation things as a kid.
One time I had masturbated and I just wanted to kind of feel like it was
somewhat,
you know,
okay.
I knew what I was doing,
but you know,
I was probably like 10.
So I went to my dad and I go,
um,
I was taking a shower that was washing,
you know,
between my legs and then this stuff came out and he goes,
they'll wash along next time
and then walked away.
And I was like,
Oh yeah,
I guess I shouldn't do that.
Yeah.
Did you feel guilty course?
So weird.
And another time I remember I approached him
when I was like,
um,
do you ever masturbate?
I just straight up asked him and he goes,
one time when I was 16
it was like,
that's it.
And he was like,
yeah,
but what would be better?
Like I was thinking about it.
Would you want your dad to talk to you about it?
Not that he would be like coming out when you watch me do something.
Not like that,
but I think,
I think the approach that I would have preferred would be like,
hey,
just so you know.
I mean,
it would have been weird,
right?
He'd be like,
yeah,
masturbating.
I'd be like,
I don't want to hear about,
he'd be like,
just so you know,
you know,
you do it in private,
in your room or in the bathroom.
It's normal to do it not 10 times a day,
but you're going to,
you know,
it's going to happen.
Like just wait,
let you know that you're in the realm of normal behavior.
Right?
Yeah.
Someone needs to tell you that.
I felt like I was a total Darrell.
Oh,
that's so interesting.
Because even like my mother bought me a book called what's happening to my body
and it was so dumb and I,
you know,
I told you about armpit hair and periods.
Yeah.
But I don't even think there was a section about masturbating.
The total it should be there should.
That should have been like chapter one.
Hey,
this is what you should be doing.
It's normal sometimes when you do this and make your pussy feel good
like that.
Right.
Are you going to talk to our son about this?
For sure.
Like what age?
Six.
Six?
No,
no,
no.
But when he's a little bit,
I don't know.
Probably like 12 getting into puberty.
Yeah.
11 amen.
Here's the rules.
Okay.
And a stroke your hormones to do.
Yeah.
Do it in the bathroom.
Try to get it down the drain
you do in your bedroom.
Oh,
this hurts my ears.
Shut the door.
Nobody wants to hear about it.
And don't make mom clean your laundry with your crusty socks and stuff.
I bet you did that right,
right.
Yeah.
You're such a dope.
Oh,
shoot it into my boxers.
Oh my God.
I'm going to throw out,
crossed up.
And then I would throw them under the bed.
So then like six to 12 pairs of frosty boxers and I would just throw them in the
laundry chute.
And
your mother did it?
Yeah.
She never said anything to you like,
Hey,
you're Chinese or kind of new.
I used to do that.
I'd be embarrassed by them.
So I would soak,
there was a sink next to our laundry machine,
I don't know,
whatever.
It's just a laundry sink and I would throw all my boxes in there and wet them.
So they would,
they would get right.
That's humane.
Yeah.
They would soak,
cause you don't really have a sense of shame.
Like I asked you to stop by the drug started to make some sexual purchases for
us.
Yeah.
And you left the bag of rubber is just,
no,
not even that.
You just took it out of the box,
put it right on the Credenza,
right in the hallway.
Whoever comes over and can just see our box or rubbers.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Do you have any sense of shame or number of the other one?
The uh,
the cock rings.
Yeah,
that was fun.
And our housekeeper put them in a plastic bag for you.
But I told you she didn't know.
She does not know.
They don't have those in her country.
She,
she just thought like,
oh,
these are new rubber bands are.
So that's why she put them in a sanitary Ziploc bag next to your bed.
She didn't say shit.
No.
That's the best part about her is that she's in these uh,
keep your cock hard.
Let me sir,
I hey,
give her cock hard caucus soft sometime if you lose weight,
maybe your cock it harder.
Yeah.
Oh,
thank you for that.
I notice you very fat,
fat,
your body fat when he erections.
But
the cock ring,
you come hard too.
I notice
she pussy is dry
lubricants like,
Oh,
I'm sorry what Nancy,
you can,
uh,
what's that value?
So her,
if you'd like to list there,
keep her pussy where if you like,
wow.
Nancy put Jesus Christ halfhearted cocking sorry of her.
How do you know it's tough nuts because we fucking Latin Koba
that'd be great if she said something be so,
she's found so much of our nasty shit.
I mean that's what house,
that's the bond.
That is the purest housekeeping.
They know all your shit.
All your to gonna tomorrow.
She's going to be like a shark this weekend in your boxers.
These are sharp boxers in the trashcan.
Oh,
I know.
Cause I'm like,
what did you do with your shitty boxers that throw them in the trash?
Well then Nancy's going to get those two.
Can we make a sharp turn here?
You see your diet makes you
stop being so fatty washout and you get hired again.
You want to talk some shit?
He already eating spicy foods.
I see.
Yeah,
that's right.
Pepper flakes in your shed.
Oh my God.
What is this here?
Have
on talk some shit.
Yeah.
What is it?
Is this getting,
we're going worse secrets.
He looks reaction.
We're going to show him.
Should I fast forward that?
Um,
yeah.
Yeah.
What's happening?
I'm doing,
I guess they showed him.
Oh.
Oh,
where did that go?
Okay.
They showed him.
Yeah,
the song,
right?
Yeah.
Pushing.
So somebody made a crazy loke song.
Great.
No,
no.
With crazy lugs.
Music.
So they basically edited right.
They helped it.
I mean that's one way of putting it.
I was saying,
oh sorry.
The right way to say that.
Yeah,
I was saying that they,
you know,
you know what I'm saying song but okay.
What I'm saying is that the song,
they played it for him in front of him.
Oh we get to see him react.
No way to his own music.
This is awesome.
We never got it
to see this part we get and we're going.
It was see crazy looks reaction.
We're going to show cause remix on Segura is podcast.
Okay.
Yeah these are great.
Can't decide what we'd love for you guys to crazy and she will do that.
I'm still me.
Thanks a lot.
Here is okay.
Crazy legs motion made by student me going on and off.
So thank you guys next week.
I was just going to keep pushing training to the red.
Crazy low.
Scotty.
He's getting
training
is awesome.
He's rapping over the song
remix.
Remix.
Yes.
You got it.
So
fairly new.
Likes it
cause he loves you.
All right.
Hello.
Okay.
He loves it.
So are you going to drawing is
lead by
check is that shall goes out to the fans and a body.
You know,
Simon,
thanks for the support to a body like a Ben say in a by keep it pushing and God
bless.
She uh,
he loves it.
Can I tell you what crazy looks?
I feel like he's finally getting the attention he deserves.
I feel like your mom's house as really facilitated that for him.
We've created yet another star.
We broke Thursday lane.
We broke Peter Kane,
we broke Auntie Fifi.
Linkedin is how flow now.
We've broken crazy blokes.
You know how many stars have come out of your mom's house?
It is ridiculous.
Um,
you know,
last week we had a big thing,
a big back and forth about,
um,
mothers,
you know how to say right.
Cry Website and like enjoy.
Let's lacroix like Saint Croix.
We left him a voicemail last week.
Right,
right.
Um,
we,
we told them,
hey,
we need to,
yeah,
I like that song now.
The song's pretty good man.
No,
it's really good.
Yeah,
I'm glad that crazy looks likes it too.
Oh yeah,
he got down to,
it was funny.
Shit.
Where is um,
pushy.
Pushy.
Okay.
I can't even open up what up my and she surely this.
Alright.
Um,
so anyways,
we left that message during the show.
I remember I called,
they wrote back to her.
Oh my goodness.
Here we go.
He says a bone.
George John Pierre.
Thank you for calling Laquana sparkling water.
We are so happy to hear that you enjoy the mango sparkling water.
We are even happier that you're pronouncing like qua correctly.
We receive hundreds of calls from fuckboys.
What Pos people pronouncing it lacroix like enjoy Ching Chong Ching Chong
dummies.
I bet they pronounced the FedEx like Fedex.
In order to correctly answer your question about carbonation making you belch
out,
not fluctuate.
At first,
my bus first share a little history on our product,
our mango sparkling water.
It was invented by Nazi scientists.
The story goes out off haler demanded the sparkling water beverage with high
carbonation so he could belch and faces of Jews in the hundreds block of
Auschwitz.
Original drink was debuted on four 20 Hitler's birthday at the Ventura Harbor
Comedy Club.
I'm seeming yes,
historical record tells us that Jews would shout,
Hey Hitler,
and if two young gentlemen were there,
it had high and tight jeans,
enough out off would belch a beef cream right in their face.
Those lucky Jews.
Even today we stay true to our original formula.
No,
what I'm saying it is good for the fewer well it is good for Mr. White folks and
big Daddy Kane sub cane.
I do have good news for you.
Likewise,
scientists are working on a special formula that guarantees double pipe classics
in every can.
This will revolutionize the soda game.
Never has a soda affected the how you say rectum and the esophagus.
At the same time that drink will be unveiled in new port titties at Carolina
September 8th,
ninth and 10th.
This is a poly by friendly establishment Dj dad mouth will be spinning records
and they will be serving a second then Chinese meal.
We look forward to seeing you there.
Please bring visa and mastercard or cash.
Um,
sincerely Kim Mann customer service.
Wow.
Thank you.
How interesting.
They drives all these references that sound familiar to it is,
it does sound familiar?
It does.
Sound familiar.
Thank you for getting back to us.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Don't roll your eyes.
I saw that you're like,
it's not like,
I mean it's Lacroix,
it's on our website.
That correct.
Matthew,
what's your favorite flavor right now?
Because we've got quite a few in the house.
We've got,
we've got mango,
apricot and strawberry.
Pineapple.
I like the star rape level the most.
Yeah,
that one's good.
Yeah.
Wait,
which one do you not like the apricot?
I think it's,
I can't remember.
It might be the mango APP.
I didn't really like it.
I didn't like the way.
What should I do with the,
um,
the different,
comparing the different ethnicities.
Oh Shit.
Can I pass really quickly?
I got a peek.
Real,
real bad.
Okay.
All right.
Uh,
how was your peachy?
Oh man,
I was so powerful.
I really had to go
bad.
I really held onto it too long.
Kind of a neat part about childbirth is I don't really feel my bladder when it's
full anymore and that just kind of have to guess.
So Nice.
Six year old style downs.
I know you ready to do this.
Yeah.
Do you guys get into it man?
Let's fucking do it.
Drink the top layer
assumptions.
Chunk
the
urine.
Why my button
or sex with your sister?
Grandmother walks on masturbating.
Never have another orgasm.
It's time to play.
Would you rather have
right.
Well that was good.
Would you rather we have a few submitted.
Um,
as always you can submit your,
would you rather is to us your mom's podcast@gmail.com these came in from Mick
puppy breath.
Um,
okay.
One of them did.
Well let's read his first time.
Would you rather have a big healthy dick and your son has to have a micro penis?
Oh Geez.
Or he gets to have a big healthy dick.
And you have the micro penis.
Ah,
kind of really interesting question because behind that,
yeah.
Well the psychology and also the love that you love your offspring so much.
Would you rather them have the great thing?
Well,
yeah,
I mean,
I've told this to you now.
If it's between you and Alice dying,
I choose you.
Thank you.
I remember that.
It's not really one of the questions that you guys are in a boat drowning.
I choose my son and then you just fucking die.
Yeah,
I remember that.
I think my answer to that was I'd hit you in the back of the head with a fucking
hammer,
a claw hammer,
and then my son would live even though he wouldn't have to hurt you.
I just,
it just for the added fun,
Fun,
thanking my death hurt,
stab you in the neck with a screwdriver.
And then I'd be like,
all right,
I lost.
Let's go.
Um,
thanks for that.
But no,
but do you,
do you understand that they're also saying,
and this one,
do you,
would you rather him suffer because he has a micro penis?
Yeah,
I know.
Or do you suffer?
And my answer is honestly,
I would take the big penis.
That's rude.
Give him the micro penis.
You know why?
Why?
He doesn't know any better.
He was a kid.
It's a baby
smile anyways.
Right now he's a baby.
Doesn't need a big old hug.
Let him have a baby peanut for the rest of his life.
He'll find other things to get good at.
That's terrible.
Yeah.
I don't want to deal with that.
Look,
I'm already not packing a lot.
If you're telling me,
let's see the micro version of this.
Whoa.
Yeah,
but you're married to me.
You're already set up.
You have love.
I would not dump you because might yeah.
Grow Collins a show it off though.
I mean,
you know,
pull it out at parties.
I do.
You know,
I'm a grown up,
right.
So yeah,
having a big old healthy one.
That'd be fun.
But you've already lived your life.
You're old.
You're already 58 years old.
I'm not done everything you want to do.
Yeah.
Give your son the healthy hog.
I'm Christina.
Would you rather your husband have the big nice one or your son?
My son.
But you get to benefit from the big nice one.
Yeah.
But I've had my big nice,
I've had 39 years of big nice ones.
Puerto Rican one's black.
One's Haitian Dominican ones.
Yeah.
It's time to let my son have a bigger heart.
I'm thinking the big healthy one.
Here's selfish man.
He'll be,
he'll be fine.
Are you being serious?
Am I being serious?
Yeah.
You're the worst,
right?
All right.
It's totally,
if I have to tell you why,
it's fine.
He'll be fine.
You're horrible,
man.
He's fine.
He'll get used to it.
You know?
See,
I've already experienced and not having my grow peanuts.
The amount of psychological trauma I would endure from accepting the micro penis
would be too.
Well,
you're married.
It doesn't matter.
It does matter.
It doesn't not showing your hog to anybody.
It doesn't matter.
Doesn't matter.
No.
Thanks.
Do you realize the amount of psychological trauma going from a normal one to a
be like what that would do and then just having a small dawn your whole life.
Exactly.
I don't know.
Listen,
this is a dick thing.
This is an I got it.
Yeah.
I'm the president of the Dixon.
I know.
Dude.
If there's one thing I know in this world's dicks and Cox and balls,
and I'm saying I'm taking it.
All right.
This is your domain,
your Dick Domain.
Fine.
Do you have one?
Yeah,
go ahead.
Okay.
What'd you rather?
Every time.
Okay.
You can go on a vacation once a year for the rest of your life.
Free vacations anywhere around the world,
but you're on a cruise.
It's always a cruise and it's always with your family.
Oh my God.
Four or you have to spend a year alone in Alaska,
Alaska,
three.
Really think about it.
It's all a long time.
All right.
Hello Alaska.
Here I come,
Juno,
but here's the thing is that anchorage,
you do get to go on a free vacation.
It is a cruise.
It's not my favorite
fishing hunting a year alone in solitude.
You go crazy a year alone.
You're not talking to anybody.
That was quick when you go work for Sarah Pailin.
Yeah.
Okay.
Join the Pailin Campaign for Paleo for president.
See,
here's the thing.
I might choose a free cruise for a year,
even though that's what every family member that I fucking can't cannot stand.
Cause here's what we did on the cruise we went on last time you buy that VIP
pass,
it gets you in the secluded areas of the ship.
You stay away from people,
which is what we did last week.
I would go crazy on that cruise.
Crazier.
I know.
Crazier than being alone.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
that was good.
Yeah.
Alaska.
Um,
but you,
Rau,
you'd take the vacation?
I would because I love vacations and I would find a way,
I mean much like in my day to day life,
I find a way to avoid my family.
My family lives in La and I don't see them.
He realized that.
Right.
I mean I struggle with for six,
seven hours with family.
Yeah.
So I mean,
my dad's a different story.
I can hang out with him.
That's your dad's amazing.
I can hang with him all day everyday,
but yeah.
No.
How about this one came in and would you rather work at a d quality hotel chain
like a hotel?
Six super eight.
Anything with a number in its name as a housekeeper for the rest of your life?
Oh,
whether there's some brutal things and you see a lot of shit.
Literal House.
Yes.
Or eat one dog shit sandwich per day for one year
and that's it.
And I'm out.
After a year,
I'd have to eat the whole sandwich.
Doesn't say a bite.
It doesn't say by,
it's the whole sandwich sandwich.
You get sick though.
You'd get really,
really sick every day.
Do you get violently ill?
No.
I'd rather just clean hotel rooms for the rest of your life.
Here's what I would do,
Bro.
I will start a side business and that hotel.
Yeah,
I'd sell weed or something or go work for big town.
You out of pocket?
Booz Allen.
Our convicted or I would start my own prostitution ring in the hospital.
I mean a hotel.
I mean look,
there's,
there's worse jobs and cleaning up hotel rooms.
I know,
but that's a rough one.
Motel six is a rough one.
Harsh.
Yeah,
it's going to suck.
but eating shit is too much.
I can't do that,
dude.
I think I would actually do the same thing except this is my life now.
There are gigs that I would prefer to eat the dog shit sandwich on.
Oh really?
Which ones would those be?
Anything dealing with human beings like having to touch them like old folks
homes.
Like what is your job was to change like old folk divers every day.
I a massage therapist.
I would hate to touch strangers.
That's the thing we talked about that I hate touching people either.
I wouldn't want to do that.
Okay.
I wouldn't be,
here's the thing,
I wouldn't want to touch me.
Right?
That's when I see Nia yet I'm fucking massage me and here's a modified version
of this one because the,
thank you.
The thinking behind this.
This is really good.
Would you rather be a prostitute for that asshole?
What's his name?
High town.
Your big towns.
Big towns.
Oh,
them wings beds or you eat the dog shit sandwich.
Oh my God.
What's I'm saying like,
yeah,
no.
Then you'd be like,
I want to get violently ill every right.
Or,
or you're like a Russian hooker.
You're like a Ukrainian third world stolen from the mafia,
by the mafia in your drug with heroin every day and you're 15 years olds and
you're the prostitute.
You know what I'm saying?
Like that's horrible too.
That's the worst job.
Like I run
this one came in,
I'll just read you this real quick from Sovos Jiang,
longtime listener,
first time,
Eli,
email time.
First Time.
Would you rather have all your browns for the rest of your life be hot
toothpaste,
shits,
you know where you need to wipe at least like eight to 13 times.
Yeah.
And most of the time there'd be still brown back there.
That's what the big days for Bro.
These are long,
hot moisty browns where you spend 30 minutes on the toilet,
you spent half the time wiping you never feel clean.
Yeah.
Just oozing out of you.
Or would you rather have a dead tooth in your mouth?
Oh fuck that.
Uh,
that you could not remove.
Fuck that.
The dead.
Who would be visible to everyone now?
Um,
oh,
it would not be visible.
It would be like a molar tooth back of your mouth.
It's a Zombie to,
but it would give you the worst breath.
That's the problem.
And it would end up eventually to Kang.
The rest of your teeth?
Yeah.
I mean you described our Brown's basically.
So I live with that.
It's like would you rather live the life you're living now or just have shit
mouth,
so yeah,
sorry.
It's two of us.
Giang but we take current Brown situation,
right?
Oh yeah.
Yeah,
definitely.
Definitely.
Um,
anything else?
Jeans?
Yeah.
Okay.
I have one.
And you're,
yeah.
Okay.
Making you laugh.
Yeah.
Hold on though.
Let me think.
I was the worst.
Oh,
I know.
Okay.
Ready?
I like this teeth idea though.
So I'm going to kind of tangential off the teeth.
Would you rather,
are you listening to me?
Have your front tooth missing.
Just one of your front teeth.
The right one just gone and you can't fix it,
man.
You're just going to have a front tooth gone for like five years or you're a Dj,
you get your sweet Dj dad mouth.
I am a DJ.
Yeah,
but the only music you can play is Garth Brooks.
I just got to find a way to make it interesting.
You've got to make scars,
rugs and do Garth Brooks music.
You're like Garth Brooks Dj,
but you can only play Garth or you have to play some Garth.
No,
no.
The only music you're allowed your oh,
catalog as a DJ is everything Garth Brooks,
the fuck is wrong with you.
Yeah.
What's his head song?
Is it inertia?
Earliest.
Damn.
That's not him,
mother.
I got friends and
we're the whiskey arts and dance.
But you're like the cool dad.
Garth Brooks.
Deejayed.
Yeah,
well the thing is missing,
so I feel about that.
He'd be like the toothless comic,
the toothless,
retarded comic.
My thing.
So my DJ appeal would be like,
come to my show.
There's going to be cool stuff.
Yeah.
I think I would take
the toothless retards calmly.
Yeah.
At least I could do what I wanted it to.
I don't want to fucking plague Garth Brooks,
but is missing tooth will ruin your life.
First of all.
You get it,
you lose me.
Okay.
I lose you for I missing you would take my micro penis but not a missing tooth
and I have to see your penis a lot of time.
Yeah,
you do.
You realize how it's going to fuck up your whole world.
Missing a tooth as a horrible,
it ruins everything.
You're not going on to smile.
I don't want to look at you.
You're going to stand with career.
People are going to be like,
it's like I'm missing a fucking put.
That becomes part of the act that becomes the part of the Ackman and the
retarded toothless comic.
Gotcha.
Okay.
Do you ever notice may or mocking you get it.
Do you get it?
You get it?
Okay.
What would you take?
You'd be the Garth Brooks.
Tj,
you're out of your mind.
You know,
find a way to make that interesting.
You can mix like you can remix the beats to make them cool loophole.
There's loopholes are not thinking about Tom.
Uh Wow.
Only one verb.
This whole episode.
No,
there was a few of you are not hear them anymore.
Yeah,
they're there.
Um,
all right.
We gotta get Outta here.
Genes.
Okay.
This song is called amaze and fan made it amazing.
What is also,
oh,
your mom's house.
podcast.com.
Tom Cigarette ICOM thousand ranch.com the store.
Will it be up and running next week?
Thank you all for listening to the show,
watching the show.
Thanks.
Mommies buy jeans.
Hygiene.
Ooh,
Ooh.
Hello.
Mommies wondering if crazy low
ranked in Israel.
Helpful.
Hello
God,
you lose mass with me.
And so,
hey
kid by himself turntables.
He should fuck getting the someone.
Yeah,
Dad.
Okay,
Gotcha.
Crazy.
Hello.
All right.